for every fan theory the last Jedi force
choked into oblivion it seems like two
new questions pop up in their place new
details and references hidden in the
movie are still emerging and some of
them are may have more meaning than you
realize
here are some of the crazy references
you missed in the last Jedi spoilers
ahead blaster damage in Return of the
Jedi Luke got smoked by a blaster bolt
while he was trying to escape Jabba's
boat over the Sarlacc pit luckily that
laser landed on Luke's fake hand and
Luke went right back to almost kicking
the bad guys into the Sun in the last
Jedi old a grumpy Luke is still one hand
down but if you look closely especially
at the part where a handsome his old
lightsaber you can see faint scorch
marks on the back of his hand a reminder
of young Skywalker's glory days
no hand Luke speaking of Luke's fake
hand director Rian Johnson himself
pointed out an inconsistency that may
reveal more for the future of the
franchise after force projecting himself
to kraid's to deal with kylo Ren Luke
vanishes from his Rock
by all accounts becoming one with the
force however there was one detail
missing from that scene as Johnson put
it we were in the other room saying a
steel hand should cling to the ground
since Luke's prosthetic hand wasn't
actually a part of him it should have
been left behind just like his Jedi robe
does that mean there's more to Luke
story probably not but you can bet or
spark a new round of theories before the
next movie k9 cameo
there was a lot going on during the
kanto bite scenes so you probably missed
one particular cameo Carrie Fisher's dog
Gary well even if you saw the alien dog
on screen you may not have recognized
her as anything special because for one
it was just a dog and for two it was
only on screen for a second according to
the dog's official Twitter account one
of the aliens in the casino was holding
a dog based on Fisher's own canine did
it mean anything to the story nope but
it was a nice nod to the late Star Wars
legend and a cool source of inspiration
if nothing else hidden knowledge one of
the big moments in the last Jedi came
when Yoda force called a lightning bolt
down to scorch the sacred tree holding
all those ancient Jedi books well as
usual Yoda had the last laugh it get to
him alien
at the end of the film afin opens our
drawing the Millennium Falcon holding
all the Jedi Tech's from the sacred tree
it gives a lot more meaning to Yoda's
final line to Luke that library
contained nothing that the girl Raiders
not already possess it was a blink in
your missing moment but rest assured
that the Jedi wisdom is safe and secure
for a new generation of force users
costumes secrets although the film never
draws attention to them the production
team in the last Jedi put a ton of
detail into the characters costumes for
example vice-admiral hollows bracelets
are a map of the constellations seen
from her homeworld
it's a crazy detail that nobody would
ever notice and it's just the beginning
poe dameron was at that class that's
usually covered up by the collar of his
jacket but a few scenes show the chain
around his neck what they don't show you
is a ring looped into the chain which is
his to see some others wedding ring
similarly ros sports the secret ring of
her own when rose in the Finneran canto
bite there's a quick moments where ROS
flashes a resistance symbol on her ring
as it turns out that's an antique left
over from the Galactic Civil War when
they were worn by Imperial senators who
had flashed the secret symbol to other
rebels to prove their allegiance to war
T glyphs supreme leader snoke has come
and gone with no new clues to his
origins well except for one which
honestly kind of lends some credence to
all those Snoke is Darth Plagueis
theories for those who don't know Darth
Plagueis was a master of Daft Sidious
until Sidious struck down Plagueis
during his rise to power you can only
see it clearly in two or three shots but
Snoke was wearing a ring in the last
Jedi located on his left hand it had a
gold base with a black stone rising out
of it according to the last Jedi the
visual dictionary the gold section is
inscribed with glyphs of the dwarfs a
dwarf planet that was home to the stages
of duarte for mysterious philosophers
who were apparently revered by the Ceph
judging by the statues of them in
Palpatine's office in Revenge of the
Sith and Attack of the Clones
the novel Darth Plagueis also suggests
that one of the statues belong to
Plagueis it isn't exactly a strong
connection to Snoke but the markings on
Snopes rings are literally one of the
handful of times Dwarfs have shown up in
Star Wars while it's doubtful that Snoke
really is Darth Plagueis the ring
suggests there may still be some
connection between the two Praetorian
symmetry like a lot of the other
characters in the last Jedi
smokes personal bodyguards the
praetorian guard were introduced then
killed off without much explanation
fortunately these faceless Red Warriors
made the most of their time on screen
and the gave audiences one of the best
fights of the franchise amidst all the
action you may have missed a particular
detail about the Praetorian guards
although there are eight of them they're
organized into four pairs with each pair
arms of identical weapons the visual
dictionary explains that this was done
to emphasise the symmetry of the
first-order philosophy what is past his
future name check if you miss Joseph
gordon-levitt's cameo in the last Jedi
you want alone nobody ever said his
character's name a during the movie in
short he voiced the alien on Kanto bite
who led the police to Finn and rose and
his name was slow and low but that name
is part of an ongoing joke from the
filmmakers to give certain characters
names pulled from Beastie Boys songs of
all things slow and low comes from the
song slow and low the force awakens has
ello Asty fond the song hello nasty rude
down from roof down and brass monkey
from brass monkey half the Star Wars
rights has finally went out of ideas for
names
not even close that happened way back
when salacious bikram showed up prime
jedi if you've ever wondered who the
first Jedi was you're not alone and the
last Jedi may have an answer on the
floor of the Jedi Temple on Luke's
island is a mosaic of the Prime Jedi the
first guy to be part of the Jedi Order
it shows up in several scenes during the
movie most clearly when Luke is telling
ray his first to breached a version of
the we need to talk about kylo story so
who is the prime Jedi does he have a
name unfortunately the movie doesn't
have any explanations there don't join
Benicio Del Toro's character DJ is
definitely an enigma he showed up got
Finn him rose onto sloped ship then sold
out the resistance and skipped out all
the richer for it but for those paying
close attention his moral ambiguity was
practically written on his forehead from
the beginning you may have caught the
metal plate on the right side of DJ's
headgear but unless you pause the movie
in the theaters you probably missed the
inscription on it don't join yep that's
what he told Finn and it's DJ's whole
philosophy up to and including his name
DJ
ache
don't join crusader crystal near the
beginning of the movie the camera moves
through Luke's hurt and rests on a few
of his belongings some fans were quick
to notice that a necklace hanging in the
hut seemed to contain a red Kyber
crystal the crystal used to power
lightsabers turns out that's exactly
what it is but the story doesn't end
there coming back to the film's a visual
dictionary it's described as a
fragmented safe lightsaber crystal but
the necklace itself is a Jedi Crusader
pendant the Jedi Crusaders were first
mentioned in Star Wars Knights of the
Old Republic they were also known as a
revin kiss
named after their leader reven a Jedi
who succumb to the darkside and became
Darth Revan that's significant because
mice of the Old Republic was purged from
the official canon although that have
been hints that the game was creeping
its way back into canon this may be the
biggest indicator about yets
does this tiny detail in the last Jedi
reinstate of revin as a canonical
character fans can only hope thanks for
watching
take the loop icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff who know your love to
[Music]